uber CEO Travis kalanick resigned
yesterday employees said goodbye and
true were fashioned by throwing up on
his backseat and giving him one star
calendar could develop the reputation is
the embodiment of the Kelly be overly
aggressive tech bro he had been facing a
seemingly unending series of scandals he
was advising Donald Trump II was caught
on tape insulting one of Hoover's own
drivers headed up a workplace with a
frat house level of sexual harassment
but what can you expect from a guy like
canonical once talked about ordering
women on demand and calling it boo
bhurji ha ha ha anyway it's very hard to
believe he was advising Trump comedians
now that the ubers tech bro and chief is
gone what do you think was in his
severance package Jenny a high-five from
Bill O'Reilly yeah by Kenny G a million
dollar credit for lyft yes hello at 3
p.m. it was 10 million dollars but after
five surge pricing brought it up to 15
million yeah fine yeah